Blackheads and clogged ears
can be super uncomfortable,
but it's important to leave any picking
and prodding to the experts.
This is how professionals treat
and clean five body parts,
including the teeth, scalp, and toenails.
This teeth-cleaning method
is called guided biofilm therapy, or GBT.
The goal is to remove
biofilm from the teeth.
It's a layer of bacteria
that's responsible for
bleeding gums, bad breath,
and some dental infections and diseases.
Unlike plaque, you can't
see or feel biofilm
because it's so tiny.
That's why dental hygienist Faye Donald
is painting each tooth
with this purple liquid.
It's an organic colored dye
called Biofilm Discloser.
It stains early biofilm,
which is less than three days old, pink
and mature biofilm,
which is more than three days old, blue.
Donald wants to disrupt early biofilm
before it has the chance
to mature into plaque.
Now the cleaning process begins.
She's using a tool called Airflow Max,
which acts like a gentle
jet wash inside the mouth.
It uses a combination of warm water
and soluble antimicrobial powder.
Donald says it'll remove
100% of the biofilm
from the teeth, even
in the dark, warm areas
that the biofilm likes to hide.
It also removes stains.
Now that that's done,
she uses a descaling kit
called Piezon No Pain.
It uses ultrasonic vibrations
to remove any remaining
hard buildup or plaque
from the teeth.
Unlike old plaque-removal methods,
there is no scraping involved,
so it won't scratch or
damage the tooth's surface.
Earwax can be soupy, hard,
crumbly, soft, and even moldy.
Professionals will scrape, suck,
or flush it out.
The removal method depends on
the consistency of the wax
and where it's located
inside the ear canal.
Here, we're looking at hard, impacted wax.
But this wax is way too impacted,
so suction isn't working.
He switches to a Cawthorne hook No. 6,
which is a tiny metal right-angle hook
with a pointy end.
It's so small that Boland
can maneuver the hook around the debris
and gently dig it out of the ear canal.
It's important that he carefully digs
and scrapes out the debris in stages.
Otherwise, painful damage
to the ear can occur.
The wax became like this
after the patient tried
to self-treat it with water-based drops.
Earwax is important for ear health,
so Boland says that it
should only ever be removed
if it's bothering the patient.
And in that case,
it's important to visit a specialist
to get it professionally removed.
Felicia Brown created a
holistic scalp cleanse
for clients with serious dandruff buildup.
To prep the scalp, she
sprays the cleansing product
directly on the client's head.
Now she's scratching
and freeing the scalp of dandruff,
dead skin, and anything
else that's clogging it.
Once the buildup is
removed, she sprays the hair
with the cleansing product again
and lets it sit for 15 to 20 minutes.
The scalp is shampooed
and thoroughly massaged.
She says clients usually experience
immediate relief after the treatment.
The scalp cleanse was made for patients
with psoriasis, eczema, dermatitis,
dandruff, or a clogged scalp.
Lori Halloway is a nail technician
who cleans thick, impacted toenails.
She starts by soaking the feet
in a whirlpool foot bath
that contains foot soap and foot salt.
This helps soften and disinfect the skin
and loosen up the debris.
She treats the bottom of the foot
with a callus remover.
Nail nippers reduce the
length of the toenail,
and a cuticle pusher pushes back the skin
that's stuck to the nail plate.
She uses an ingrown-toenail
sidewall cleaner
to carefully pull out all
of the impacted debris
from the sides and underneath the toenail.
She often uses an electric file
to reduce the thickness of the nail.
When a toenail is too thick,
it hits the top and front of the shoe.
This is what causes it to grow abnormally,
which can lead to infection or injury.
Claudia Colombo is an esthetician
who professionally performs
blackhead extractions.
Before the extraction process begins,
she massages the face
to drain the lymph nodes
and gently cleanses the skin.
Then she pre-softens the
skin with a warm towel
and an enzyme treatment.
This makes it easier for the blackheads
to be extracted.
That silver spatula is actually
an ultrasonic skin scrubber,
which Colombo uses to exfoliate the skin.
The ultrasonic waves help loosen
and remove oil and dirt from the pores.
She starts gently
extracting the blackheads
with her fingers.
Not much pressure is needed,
since the skin has already
been prepped and softened.
It's important to replenish the skin
with minerals and nutrients
that may have been lost
during the process.
In this case, Colombo
applies some chlorophyll
and copper complex to replenish magnesium
and copper in the skin.
She leaves it to incubate
and then applies a blue
light to help heal the skin.
The light also allows the ingredients
to penetrate deeper into the pores.
Lastly, she applies a hydro jelly mask
to soothe the skin.